Pour ne louper aucune vidéo
abonnez-vous etactivez la petite cloche !
Salut les Épicurieux.
Vous savez ce que c'est ?
Une coquille d'huître
quine va pas me servir à vous parler
de l'origine de ce coquillage
mais du mot
« ostracisme ».
Une attitudequi consiste à exclure
un individu ou un groupe.
Ostracisme
vient du grec
« ostrakon ».
Je saisça ne s'invente pas
même si je le prononce à la française.
Un mot qui signifie au sens propredu terme
« coquille d'huître ».
Mais quel rapport entre la mise à l'écart d'un individu
et lacoquille ?
Le terme « ostracisme »
a été utilisé dès le Vème siècle,
avant notre ère,
dans laGrèce Antique.
Lors des assemblées publiques,
on votait le bannissement temporaire
d'unepersonne considérée
dangereuse pour la cité.
Les citoyens inscrivaient leur vote
sur unecoquille
comme celle-ci.
L'ostracisme signifie donc
« le verdict par les huîtres ».
L'histoire neraconte pas si avant de voter,
on les dégustait.
Tiens,
à la question faut-il manger des
huîtres avec du pain et du beurre ?
Moi je vote,
oui !